only on CBS this morning how one
family's heartbreak is fueling a new
call for drivers to put down your phones
behind the wheel the CDC estimates about
nine people die every single day in the
US due to distracted driving crashes now
the American Medical Association is
joining safety advocates to call for
tougher laws banning hell handheld cell
phone use in all 50 states
Kris Van Cleave is joining us from
Washington with more on this story
Kris we see it on the road every single
day how big is the problem it's a big
problem Gail good morning the latest
research finds about a third of drivers
say texting is their biggest driver
distraction and it appears to be getting
worse drivers were 57 percent 57 percent
more likely to be doing something on
their phone than they were just four
years earlier now when you're doing that
you take your eyes off the road and
looking away for as little as two
seconds can double your crash risk and
in that time you can travel the distance
of up to a football field for the Weaver
family that was all the time it took to
change their lives forever
a texas-sized silence the sound of
heartbreak of loss haunts Patrick and
Elena Weaver if you had been here a year
ago it was just a buzz of activity now
Jonathan's friends they were always over
here now we pull up and it's dark
there's nobody here it's almost
unbearable nine months ago they lost
their only son 18 year old Jonathan in a
horrific distracted driving crash that
killed three robbers a police body
camera shows what was left of the truck
Jonathan was driving after it was hit
head-on by a pickup owned by energy
transfer partners according to the
accident report police believe it's
driver James darling
may have been distracted by a porn video
on his phone when he swerved into
oncoming traffic
he hit Weaver with so much force the
teens truck was compressed by almost six
feet
that police report says after the crash
last April paramedics found darlings
phone still playing the x-rated movie
I'm not an angry person by nature and as
time goes on I'm definitely dealing with
anger over that because again to me it's
so so senseless watching porn cellphone
use he killed my phone we were a high
school champion calf roper was set to
start college on a rodeo scholarship for
a dad that's was to protect my son and I
couldn't help him you know one of us
could help my son The Weavers just filed
a new lawsuit they hope is a wake-up
call to corporate America about
distracted driving lawyer
chip Brooker energy transfer is a
billion-dollar company that has the
resources to monitor and detect this
sort of conduct with their drivers
distracted driving was blamed for nearly
3,000 deaths in 2018 an October survey
found 48 percent of drivers admitted to
reading a text roughly one in four said
they update social media take pictures
or video while driving 48 states in the
District of Columbia have banned texting
and driving but only 21 states plus DC
prohibit drivers from holding their cell
phones the American Medical Association
is now calling for all states to adopt
similar laws please put your phones down
your life and the other people's lives
are valuable put the phones away it can
wait
The Weavers say it's that message - put
the phone down that inspired them to
share their pain now energy transfer
partners the pipeline company that owned
the other truck involved in this
accident tells CBS News in a statement
our hearts go out to all those impacted
by this tragic accident
however accident reconstruction analysis
suggests that our employee was not at
fault
beyond that we declined to further
discuss specific personnel pending
litigation Tony I can only imagine what
the weavers are going through but it's a
good thing they spoke out Chris that's a
powerful story thank you very much it's
another example and we keep hearing them
over and over again about what happened
the consequences of that I saw a study
once that said what people are texting
their final text lol heading home home
soon nothing that could not wait and
that's what I think is so frustrating I
think they have to figure out that
technology has to do it yes people are
not going to self-police themselves
people or not when the car is in motion
maybe there's something and you're
behind the drivers might see your phone
does not work and as Chris pointed out
it can literally just be two seconds
that's all it takes
you're on there no you're a harder
person on technology